I'd like to briefly introduce bill
mckibben he leads needs a little
introduction by me my name is matthew
connolly I'm a professor in the history
department and I direct the Hertog
global strategy initiative but it might
make sense is to explain the occasion
this is the last in a series of lectures
we've had over the summer on climate
change and global governance this is a
program where over the last four years
thanks to the help of Roger Hertog and
her talk foundation we've looked at a
series of threats that are transnational
in nature and global in scope including
nuclear proliferation pandemics and last
summer religious violence but as I as I
think back about this past summer I
can't imagine doing any of this without
the help of of Jim Fleming who's been
critical in the work that we've done and
that we continue doing this lecture
series as part of a larger program much
of it is in the nature of research this
the research that our students are doing
I think you'll be hearing about for
years to come
the idea is that there are problems in
the world that we can compartmentalize
in one country and we can study with one
discipline what we're trying to do is to
blow the walls down in a university to
liberate the people inside to work on
the problems in this world the problems
that really matter and I can't imagine
anyone concluding this series who could
do a better job of that than Bill
McKibben
because after all Bill McKibben has
organized a campaign that is
transnational on nature and now global
in scope three fifty.org has had
demonstrations in every country except
North Korea and I'm sure the North
Koreans are not going to hold out for
long but just to you know point out he's
somebody who he's written a dozen books
maybe the most important of all in
historical terms even the end of nature
I think it's something that historians
are gonna be writing about for a long
time to come
book that's been translated in over a
dozen or two dozen languages now he's
somebody who's obviously assembled vast
knowledge working on climate change for
some 25 years now but he's also again
someone who as we would hope of our
students and others
is trying to apply that knowledge in a
way that makes a positive difference in
the world so in all these ways I want to
thank Bill McKibben for joining us and I
want to thank all of you for coming out
to hear him thank you for organizing
this excellent program which really is a
model for the kind of ways that we
should be thinking about and studying
these things climate change more than
almost anything I can think of demands a
kind of interdisciplinarity to make even
the slightest sense of it in fact it's a
good reminder that we should think about
it less as a problem an issue a crisis
and more as a kind of lens through which
to look at the world we spent the last
hundred years looking at the world
through a very economic lens and the
question that we asked before we decided
most things was will this make the
economy grow larger and if the answer
was yes then we generally decided it was
a good idea if we're wise and maybe even
if we're not we may be forced to spend
this century looking at the world
through a different lens a lens saying
does this contribute to the ongoing
physical survival of the planet or not
and really that's the place we're all
begin you guys have spent those of you
in this program have spent the last what
10 or 12 weeks studying thinking about
climate change sort of full-on and in
that 10 or 12 weeks we've seen record
heat in parts of this planet in the UK
where they've had the hottest stretch of
weather they've ever had in China today
and really for the last week where
they've been setting all kinds of
records in Alaska where we've seen
incredible heat we've seen record
flooding in large parts of the world in
diverse parts of the world 5,000 people
dead in India and the worst monsoon
tragedy ever recorded their record
flooding in places like Calgary and
Toronto
yeah good oh I don't need any pictures
for a minute so I'm for a moment we'll
just do virtual PowerPoint and I'll just
say things in the picture will come into
your head you know if I do it correctly
those are just now the kind of daily
manifestations of a planet that we have
managed to begin to upend and up and in
the most this is the most significant
thing by far that human beings have ever
figured out how to do in the lifetimes
of everybody in this room we have left
the Holocene the ten thousand year
period of benign climatic stability that
covers the entire recorded history of
the human species the period of benign
stability that underwrote the rise of
human civilization we are now out of the
Holocene and we're going into something
else and that's by far the biggest thing
that will happen in the lifetime of
anybody in this room so far we've raised
the temperature of the earth about one
degree Celsius okay which doesn't sound
like that much and in some sense it
isn't that much it's only the carbon
we've put in the atmosphere is trapping
that a little bit less than
three-quarters of a watt of extra solar
energy per square meter of the Earth's
surface you know so less than one of
those small white Christmas tree lights
per square meter of the Earth's surface
the trouble is there are a lot of square
meters on the surface of the earth and
hence that adds up to a huge amount of
energy I mean people have tried to
measure it in sort of other terms it's
the equivalent of about 400,000
Hiroshima's sized bombs a day in terms
of heat energy but those are kind of
pointless measurements really we can
tell what it's doing how big it is by
looking at what it's doing by the end of
last summer 80%
the sea-ice that was in the Arctic 40
years ago was gone okay so think about
how much energy it takes to melt the
millennia old sheets of ice on the ocean
in a very cold place you know think
about how much energy that requires and
then think about I mean I was saying to
people earlier this afternoon we should
think about that sort of thing more
often when the destruction of the Arctic
is not some remote thing I mean we took
one of the six five six largest physical
features on earth one of the things you
can see from outer space and we broke it
and we did it in the course of a few
decades and we're doing the same thing
to everything else I mean look at the
ocean it is if you stick a strip of pH
paper in the ocean now it comes out a
different color than it did 40 years ago
we managed to take the oceans which are
our metaphor for vastness and so far
we've made them about 30% more acidic
over the course of 40 years that's a
pretty large change on solid ground the
thing we noticed most to think is
changes in hydrology in the way that
water moves around the planet the basic
physical fact of this century is going
to turn out to be that warm air holds
more water vapor than cold so the
atmosphere is about five percent wetter
than it was 40 years ago that's a
staggering change in the most basic of
physical parameters on earth and what it
means is that the drought that the dice
are loaded for drought and for flood and
so now we just see them routinely on an
epic scale on mob money epic last summer
in this country we managed to make it
hot and dry enough that we could not
grow food on the most fertile farmland
on earth okay the year before that we
managed to make it so wet in say the
region up above from the Khyber Pass up
the nail on that edge of the Amalia's
that pack
and flooded to the point where a quarter
of the country was underwater and 21
million people were driven out of their
homes I mean that's biblical scale
flooding I mean the precedent for that
is Noah you know that's that's the kind
of world that just now routinely we see
operating and here's the scary part okay
that's what this looks like at the very
beginning of the global warming era
we've raised the temperature one degree
so far okay but the same scientists who
told us that was going to happen
confidently tell us now that we're
looking at four or five degrees before
the century is out Celsius so eight or
nine degrees or more Fahrenheit unless
we get off coal and gas and oil very
quickly more quickly than any government
certainly our own plans to get off it
going forward uh there is no reason to
think that civilization in the ways that
we have known it civilization that
produces great cities and great
universities and things can't cope with
anything like that change the
researchers the agronomist at Stanford
in University of Washington put out a
study a couple of years ago that just
looked at the effect on grain yields of
rises in global average temperature
forget droughts forget flood forget all
the other problems for farmers just the
fact that as it gets warmer it gets
harder to grow grain what they found was
that from this point on each degree
increase in global average temperature
should cut grain yields about ten
percent it was easy to see looking at
the Midwest last summer how that's
possible it got too hot there for corn
to fertilize if the temperatures above
95 degrees for a certain length of time
corn kernels won't fertilize trillions
of kernels of corn didn't fertilize last
summer and hence were not available to
people to eat ten percent for each
degree of extra warming you all know
enough about the world to be able to
just do the math in your head imagine a
world that's two or three degrees warmer
with the
of disruptions that we see from things
like sandy becoming more routine and
with twenty or thirty percent fewer
calories on that planet then try to
imagine any of the things you care about
development women's issues war and peace
anything else what happens to those in
that world
nothing good we can't let anything like
that happen we've got to try and arrest
climate change at as low a level as we
can we're not going to stop it it is too
late for that to have happened we've
already raised the temperature one
degree we are basically at the point
where if we do everything right we're
gonna see it go up about two degrees and
that's going to be incredibly difficult
to deal with but what we're fighting for
now is to make prevent the situation
where it becomes literally impossible to
deal with okay and that's what I mostly
want to talk about today just how that
fight is going and how we're trying to
build it and let me say that you know
since we're in a university here which
is a kind of happily a sort of temple of
Reason let me say that it took me a long
time to figure out that reason was not
going to be what would carry the day in
this fight I'm a writer by trade and so
you know my thought my contribution this
would be to write a book and I did I
wrote a book and a lot of people read it
and when I wrote the book I was 27 my
theory of change in the world was people
will read my book and and they will
change you know um that that's what it
would take and that clearly wasn't gonna
happen but still one imagined that the
kind of sum total of all the books and
scientific reports and things would be
enough that every year heroes of the
scientific fight including people here
at Columbia people like Wally Broecker
or most paramount the greatest climate
scientist maybe the greatest scientist
that we have on the planet Jim Hanson
you know going up to cap
he'll year after year after year after
year that this would be enough
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh saying we're faced the
biggest problem we've ever faced here's
what to do about it
The Economist's come in right after them
for 25 years and say relatively simple
what steps we need to take we need to
put a serious price on carbon to reflect
the damage that it does in the
atmosphere one's assumption
my assumption anyway was that this would
eventually result in changes in policy
that we would take these steps in order
to ward off disaster we never took them
we have had a 25 year bipartisan effort
in this country to accomplish nothing
and it's been entirely successful and so
at a certain point relying on reason
alone is a mug's game you know a fool's
errand it becomes time to try and figure
out why it isn't working and what to do
about it and there are a lot of answers
to that question but I think by far the
biggest answer to that question is has
to do with power and power in this case
of the fossil fuel industry of the
relatively small number of people who
make an almost unbelievable sum of money
maintaining the status quo in its
current form they have been extremely
effective advocates for nothing ever
changing it turns out that the easiest
thing to do is to block change instead
of caused it and that if you are the
wealthiest industry on earth chances are
you're going to be able to block change
certainly that's been the story in this
country and in this world and so at a
certain point some of us began to think
about how it was we might be able to
counter the power of that industry we
knew we weren't going to do it with
money because there isn't never going to
be a pile of money as big
is the fossil fuel industry yes I mean
literally Exxon made more money last
year than any company in the history of
money okay
um they have I'm no theologian but they
have more money than God you know they
they have all the money and if you only
gonna fight it they come they're gonna
win so what do you do in that situation
well historically what you do is stop
relying on reason alone and start using
that reason to build movements and
movements are in essence a way to find
other currencies to work in that aren't
the currencies of the powerful their
currencies like passion and spirit and
creativity numbers and we have to figure
out how to make those add up to more
than that money so that's what we've
been trying to do we started 350.org
5 years ago and I see out in the
audience and I hope she will stand up my
one of the there were seven of us who
started it and one of the very first
collaborators and now the executive
director of 350.org is maybe
when I met Mae she was a college
undergraduate in fact all the other
seven people who started 350.org
were all college undergraduates and so
it was a preposterous idea really to
think that we would do what we decided
we wanted to do which was launched a
global movement to do something about
climate change we had no money we had
seven undergraduates and there are seven
continents so each one took one okay and
we set to work Mae was in charge of
North America which actually means some
way she had the easiest assignment at
least she spoke the same language as
most of the people in her area of
responsibility you know so we set to
work and our work we took the name
350.org which is a kind of odd name we
took it for two reasons
one was it in early 2008 working from
his office and a hundred and tenth and
Broadway
Jim Hansen and his team at Goddard
declared that this was really the most
important number on earth they published
a paper saying 350 parts per million co2
is the most we could safely have in the
atmosphere that above that level we
can't have we can't we can't have a
planet similar to the one on which
civilization developed into which life
on Earth is adapted okay which is quite
strong language for scientists to use
and of course it's stronger language
still if you know that at the moment
we're well above 350 parts per million
we passed 400 this spring we go up to
parts per million per year were way too
high that's why the Arctic melted you
know because there's too much carbon in
the atmosphere so that was one reason we
took the name the other reason was we
were going to work around the world
well Arabic numerals translate across
linguistic
Driss okay we figured that was necessary
instead of trying to come up with a
slogan or a phrase or something that the
numbers would have to do the work the
work at first of movement-building was
just to find people like ourselves
around the planet most of the planet you
don't necessarily find quote
environmentalists unquote but there is
always somebody every place you go
interested in development in hunger in
in peacemaking and all the things that
are impossible on a degrading planet and
those were our first natural allies and
we sought them out all over the world
and we said we should um we should try
to take this number and inject it into
the bloodstream of the planet and we
decided to do it in the course of a
single day in the fall of 2009 a year
after we started we told everybody to do
something that day to Britain we had no
idea how it would go because as I say we
you know there were eight of us and it
was a pretty amateur operation and so on
and so forth um we got the first sense
that it might gonna work two or three
days early May and I and the rest were
sitting around in a borrowed office in
lower Manhattan we were one room around
a desk with our laptops open doing all
the last-minute work and the satellite
phone rang and it was our leader in
Ethiopia and like many of our leaders
around the world like many of our
leaders around the world she was a she
and she was 17 years old and in charge
of Ethiopia and she was in tears on the
satellite phone and she said the
government took away our permit for
Saturday okay when can't hold our rally
then like we were planning to so we're
going ahead and doing it today before
they can stop us okay which was brave
but that wasn't why she was in tears she
just kept saying we wanted to do it the
same day as everybody else we wanted to
be part of it with everybody else we
don't want to spoil it for me buddy
we're so looking forward to do
everybody else and we have 15,000 people
out in the street young people right now
chanting 350 so we were like okay don't
worry about the date it's alright you
know this is good and it was from that
moment on that things you know if the
next I know but maybe the next 72 hours
were some of the most moving days of my
entire life
watching these pictures flood in from
around the world second one actually
came from US soldiers in Afghanistan who
made a 350 with sandbags said were
parking our Humvee for the weekend and
and walking okay um but before the
weekend was over there have been 5,200
demonstrations in 181 countries CNN
called it the most widespread day of
political action in the planets history
and what for me was most moving was to
see that just to see the faces of people
I'd spent much of my life hearing that
environmentalism was something that rich
white people did and if you had to worry
where your next meal was coming from you
wouldn't be an environmentalist and bla
bla bla bla bla and before the weekend
was half over it was clear to me that
that was utter nonsense that most of the
people that we were working with around
the world were poor and black and brown
and Asian and young because that's what
most of the world is made up of and
oddly enough they're just as interested
in the future as anybody else maybe more
so because the future bears down very
hard on you if you're in more vulnerable
places and I mean look there's I mean we
were in that picture blew me away
those are dugout canoes someplace on the
Congo River above Kinshasa so basically
the place that Conrad in his Eurocentric
way identified as the heart of darkness
on the planet okay and it is poor I mean
they didn't have a digital camera they
took a picture and developed it in
someone's home darkroom and it didn't
come out very well so they wrote in what
the banner had said you know on
their thing but that there they were
connected up you know with the t-shirt
even you know ready to go I'll blew my
mind and I my mind was blown over and
over and over again people's creativity
was immense and there were beautiful
pictures and great ones coming in from
all over the place for the first time
the big involvement of religious
communities in this kind of work that's
the head of Muslim South Africa this
guy's kind of the leader of indigenous
traditions there's Desmond Tutu
successor is Anglican Archbishop at the
head of a big multi-faith march across
Cape Town
there's our biggest evangelical college
in this country building Graham's alma
mater there would not have been in an
environmental demonstration there even a
few years ago and it's a very good sign
that it's starting to happen
I'd been to Bethlehem to do some
organizing so not an easy place even to
get to write at the moment but the Dead
Sea is shrinking very rapidly as
temperatures rise so people wanted to do
something too many military checkpoints
in the way for so that Jordanian said
we'll make the three on our Shore the
Palestinian said we'll do the five on
our Beach the Israelis said we're good
for the big zero you know and it was it
was a beautiful day and it got a lot of
coverage because it's rare for people to
a good sign of people putting down their
kind of you know really focusing on the
most critical of problems three hundred
big demonstrations across China China
not always an easy place for this kind
of thing the police broke up one of them
okay but the others went off as planned
and that's good China's a key part of
this story and a really interesting part
they're doing lots of things wrong
pouring coal coal smoke into the
atmosphere they're doing lots of things
right leading the world in the
installation of renewable energy in a
lot of ways those were our brothers and
sisters in the Maldives one of my
favorite places incredibly poignant it's
a 5,000 year old culture in this
archipelago that stretches 1,200 miles
across the equator in the Indiana
they're unlikely to be a 50 100 year old
culture the highest point in the
archipelago's may be a metre and a half
two meters above sea level okay which is
a bad place to be in this century but
they are trying those the Student
Association holding their meeting in the
lagoon the president of the country
Mohamed Nasheed taught his entire
cabinet how to scuba dive they held an
underwater cabinet meeting against their
dying coral reef to sign a 350
Proclamation that they sent to the UN so
they're doing what they can
this was the biggest thing on Google
News for about 36 hours and I think the
reason was that people didn't look the
way that editors thought
environmentalists were supposed to look
like
that's a Yemen which might be the
toughest country on earth at the moment
and that zero is all women in full black
burka so to us they don't look like
members of the Sierra Club but you know
but their hearts are in exactly the same
place they're not thinking about
themselves they're thinking about the
future they're thinking about their kids
and their grandkids and the larger
planet and the larger good and that
thing was going on all over the world
you know sometimes they're thinking
about themselves this is the oil-rich
shape dome of Abu Dhabi you can see some
oil-rich sheiks right down front and
their dish Dasha's but um they may be
smarter than your average oil men
because there in the back is the edge
just the edge of the largest solar array
on planet earth you know these guys I
think are thinking we might like to be
rich no matter what you know and and
headed in that direction there were also
four or five hundred pictures that just
ended up in a file labeled 350 adorable
you know and and they were adorable
there is no question but they were also
really hard to look at I look at the
eyes of that girl in the middle every
time an economist or a tear up I mean
good chance that they're gonna be
refugees in the course of their lifetime
as their country is going to be
underwater not because of anything they
did obviously um so it's you know it's
hard powerful
um and we've kept doing stuff like this
we've held about 20,000 rallies I could
literally show you pictures all day all
night well into you know the next three
days just without ever repeating just on
and on and on and they make me very
happy to see the kind of spread of human
energy and place after place and this
was important educational work that
we've been up to taking this sort of
climate change idea all over the world
two places for including large parts of
this country where people weren't
focused on it one of the things that
interested us was that nobody had a
people had said when we started 350
dollar it's much too complicated a name
and too scientific and it's assigned no
one will understand it everybody
understood it it's incredibly easy to
understand it's a number we're above the
number you know were too high there's
too much and people got that everywhere
and and and they got it with the help of
art there's a Thom Yorke of Radiohead
assembled 3000 of his closest friends
and gave them all blue raincoats to make
this image of King Canute trying to hold
back the rising seas on Brighton Beach
we did this day of art projects so big
that you had to view them really from
outer space with it we had a satellite
company kicked in half a million dollars
worth of satellite times we could get
these images from all over the the world
that's one of my favorites that some in
Santa Fe and now a dry riverbed and when
the satellite came over a few thousand
people flipped these blue sheets
overhead to kind of bring it back to
life for a minute powerful beautiful
image so the first aim of movements is
to educate to build a movement to get a
lot of people they're caring about
something and that's really important
work and it's worth we keep doing but at
a certain point movements have to go
beyond that also and start really trying
to match power with power to do what
they can
to sort of force the issue especially in
a case like this where we have a very
short period of time in which to work
unlike other social movements you know
dr. King always said in almost every
speech he'd quote from I think from
Lowell he'd say um the arc of the moral
universe is long but it bends toward
justice this may take a while but we're
gonna win the arc of the physical
universe is short and it bends toward
heat and if we don't win quickly we're
not gonna win so the the one feels
impelled all the time to up the ante to
push hard the one of the vehicles that
we've chose for this may and I on others
a couple years ago was this so-called
Keystone pipeline out of the tar sands
of Canada we chose it for a couple of
reasons
one was the tar sands of Canada have a
lot of carbon in them as Jim Hansen
again did the calculations for us the
go-to guy for thinking about climate
science he did a little paper said if
you could burn everything all the
economically recoverable oil all the
stuff that Canada is aiming to get out
of the tar sands in Alberta that one
deposit of oil up there would be enough
to run the atmospheric concentration of
carbon from 400 parts per million
already too high to 540 parts per
million just that one part of Alberta
okay so I mean we can't literally can't
burn it and do anything about climate
change there's seven or other eight
seven or eight other places like that
around the world that we have to keep in
the ground because there's just too much
carbon but this was one of them so
that's one of the reasons we went to
work and the other reason was that um
the President himself was going to get
to make the decision about this pipeline
through a kind of strange quirk in the
law because they wanted to run a
pipeline across the border it required a
Presidential Permit
a law that basically in the past had
been invoked mostly to determine
things like bridges between New
Brunswick and Maine and things but they
needed this permit for the pipeline and
so we thought well we'll try because
it's such a big deal everybody told us
that there was no hope that it was a
done deal and it was gonna get approved
the way that every other pipeline had
been approved in fact in the National
Journal the kind of trade paper for
Capitol Hill they took a poll of their
300 Energy insiders lobbyists and Hill
staffers and things like that and 97% of
them said this was summer 2011 that uh
TransCanada Company would have its
permit for the pipeline by the end of
2011 so the odds were not good but we um
decided to go to work and that August so
two years ago now two years ago in a
couple of weeks we organized what became
the largest civil disobedience action in
thirty years in this country and over
the course of two weeks twelve hundred
and fifty-three people went off to jail
and then it started to spread around the
world and they had the biggest civil
disobedience action in Canada in many
years up on Parliament up on Capitol
Hill Parliament Hill and then you know
our allies and much of the rest of the
world started sitting in it consulates
and things and embassies and then we
followed the president all around the
country wherever he went something we're
still doing you know he'd be greeted
he'd go to college campuses and yes
people were happy to see him but there
are big sections of them chanting yes we
can stop the pipeline you know and then
we a couple of months later in November
exactly a year before the 2012 election
circled the White House with people five
deep shoulder to shoulder around that
mile and a half perimeter of the White
House the first time people had tried to
do that and it was a gorgeous day and
four days later the president said okay
we're gonna take a year and study this
more thoroughly
now everybody said oh a lot of people
said oh it's just cynical and he's just
trying to get it past the election in
the minute the election is over he'll
approve it and we're now in that phase
obviously
it's possible he'll approve it but I
think it's increasingly likely that
maybe this movement might actually take
an important win here the president said
in his first comment on this a few weeks
ago first public comment ever he said
what will decide will be based on
whether this adds carbon to the
atmosphere or not and if he applies that
standard in good faith then there is no
way he can permit that pipeline if he
does permit it we will know he was
acting in bad faith and we will know
that he is being the kind of thing that
people have caricatured him for being
you know all talk and little action but
if he does the right thing it'll be an
important moment it'll be the first time
that a world leader has said here's a
big thing that we're not going to do
because of the damage it will do to the
climate and that would be an enormous
legacy and it would be a great wedge a
kind of opening reopening of the
international negotiations that we
desperately need to have around climate
change so an important thing most of all
a symbol that this movement has grown
large enough and noisy enough that it
can begin to take on that financial
strength of the fossil fuel industry
because in that same period they've run
probably a hundred million dollars worth
of TV ads over and over and over again
saying that this pipeline you know would
I mean who knows what I mean every
possible good thing short of curing
leukemia you know they've attributed to
all of it nonsense
and none of it really working you know
because the movement has gotten there
now of course even were we to
successfully block said pipeline it
would be a very small step indeed in the
actual process of stopping climate
change we need to stop all kinds of
things
there's pipelines running every which
way and coal ports that they're trying
to build in the Pacific Northwest and so
on and so forth and in same in countries
around the world
we have to fight them all but really
it's impractical to imagine beating
global warming one pipeline at a time
stopping just stopping bad things we
also have to figure out how to go on
offense against this industry how to
cause them serious problems and so in
the last year what we've tried to do
with the help of many many many allies
some of whom are in this room has
launched this campaign of divestment to
try and get people to sever their
financial ties with the fossil fuel
industry and the logic of it actually
came out of a piece that I wrote but you
spent a year ago a year ago for Rolling
Stone for those of you who keep your
back issues it was the one with Justin
Bieber on the cover okay but strangely
strangely the editor called up the next
day to say your piece has ten times as
many likes on Facebook as if Justin's
and in fact it became one of the most
widely shared pieces in the magazine's
history not because it was so well
written but because the math in it it
was called I think the terrifying new
math of global warming or something was
daunting enough that people really I
mean for me it was revelatory what it
came from was this work that this team
of financial analysts in the UK had done
and they've done something we should
have done a long time ago they went
looked at all the annual reports and SEC
filings and things of the fossil fuel
industry and determined that the fossil
fuel companies and the countries that
operate like fossil fuel companies think
Venezuela had already identified
reserves equivalent to about twenty
seven twenty eight hundred Giga tons
worth of co2 2,800 billion tons worth of
co2 that is if you burned the coal and
gas and oil that they've announced that
they're planning to burn that they've
told
investors that they're going to burn
that their borrowed money against it
would release into the atmosphere 2,800
gigatonnes the trouble is that the
scientists have told us now with an
almost endless array of computer models
that the most we could burn and have
some hope of staying below that 2 degree
target that in itself is not a very good
place one degree melted the Arctic we
don't really want to go to but if we
want to stay below it we can burn about
500 Giga tons more carbon that is to say
they have five times as much carbon as
even the most conservative governments
on earth think would be safe to burn
that is to say that they'd have to leave
80 percent of it in the ground if we're
to have any chance that is to say if
they carry out their business plan the
planet tanks that is to say they are to
be understood as a rogue industry a
force that if this end of the stories
written if we can't change that then
there's no longer any room for doubt or
speculation or wishful thinking we know
what's going to happen the planets gonna
burn up and and and they're apparently
cool with that because they've ghosts
what their business plan calls for you
know and that means the rest of us can't
be cool with it and hence we launched
this divestment campaign less to try and
bankrupt them more to turn them to sort
of politically bankrupt them to turn
them into the pariahs that they are and
weaken their ability to endlessly
dominate events in places like
Washington me inspiration came from the
successful movement to divest from
companies doing business in apartheid
South Africa and generation and go and
indeed some of the leaders were the same
people maybe for us the most important
and certainly the most moving kind of
piece of video that we got as we
launched this tour around the country
last fall came from someone who'd been
a350 advisor from the beginning Desmond
Tutu in South Africa who won the Nobel
Peace Prize for his work
among other things helping spur the
divestment movement a quarter century
ago and who said if you could see what
was going on in Africa the drought the
famine you would understand why I'm
asking you to take up this same weapon
again look Desmond Tutu is one of the
three or four people on this planet who
have earned the right to be listened to
absolutely and taken with utter
seriousness and we did and we're doing
our best to demand that everybody else
do to three hundred and eighty college
campuses now in this country in the
course of six months have active
divestment fights underway six or seven
of them have already divested 15 of our
major cities have already divested
Seattle San Francisco Providence a first
big religious denomination in this
country the United Church of Christ
divested a few weeks ago there's
momentum here and there needs to be a
lot more there's great work and going on
in New York all over the place in fact
there's a minute grow divestment if you
go to I'm looking for the URL here well
somebody here is from Gro divestment
wave your hand so everybody knows who
you are okay and confined you and there
are people working on Columbia and
Barnard divestment and people working at
NYU and people working lots of other
places Edie is not alright to pay for
your education or if you're a faculty
member to pay for your salary by
profiting from the wreckage of the
climate it's not okay
this is moral the deeply moral issue and
it's a deeply practical one and so we
will fight as hard as we can we will not
win everywhere right away it'll take a
couple of years as it did in South
African times before the trustees of
essentially conservative institutions
like Columbia do the right thing but
those years will be well spent in this
fight in the educational struggle to
make sure everybody understands exactly
who places like Columbia
are in bed with and what that means okay
and so I'm trusting that all of you who
are at places like that or who are
alumni of places like that will do what
you can to make sure that that leverage
is exerted and exerted soon and strongly
um this fights gonna get just more
interesting as time goes on it's gonna
get more interesting for a couple of
reasons and really if I were the fossil
fuel industry though groups like 350 and
environmentalism in general and things
look kind of puny now I I would be
worried or I the Koch brothers I think
they're on the losing side of history
and I think it's only a question of how
quickly we can make them lose and how
much of the planet we can preserve I
think they're on the losing side of
history for two reasons one every day
now the technology that's going to
replace them gets better and clearer
what it is the few places around the
world that have taken this challenge
seriously are doing remarkable things
the Germans are probably the best exact
and an avian country that's taken
seriously this challenge okay and
there's something ironic about that I
mean Germany caused way more than its
share of 20th century problems okay but
they are busy providing some solutions
to the biggest ones of the 21st century
there were days this summer when Germany
generated more than half the power it
used from solar panels within its
borders okay that's not because look
some of you have been to Germany it's
kind of you know it's sort of foggy and
venerian there you know munich is north
of montreal think what a country could
do that had oh I don't know Florida
Texas California Nevada New Mexico
Arizona Utah to work with you know but
there are more solar panels in Bavaria
than there are in the United States and
that's because they've had the political
will to get things done
and we can build that political will and
it'll make it easier because the Germans
and others are showing the way forward
showing that this technology is real and
that it works the second the other
reason that the Koch brothers at all
should be worried is because this
movement to stand up to them has a very
effective recruiting sergeant and that
recruiting sergeant is Mother Nature
now Daley demonstrates the folly of
keeping on with what we're doing a
little more than a year ago at 350.org
we asked we just sent out the call
around the network to ask people to
organize in places that had felt the
sting of climate change you know we
called it connect the dots and we though
were used to organizing things on a big
scale we're pretty amazed with the
number of things places around the world
where people were spontaneously kind of
doing things to sort of let their pain
be seen it was actually a funny day the
day we were starting was a was a Friday
I guess row you know on a weekend and
that morning the big climate change
denier group funded by the fossil fuel
industry put up all these billboards
that's Ted Kaczynski and he's I mean
their argument apparently was Ted
Kaczynski had believed in global warming
therefore only crazy serial killers
believe in global warming us I mean it's
not even like a good mean it's like you
know Hitler believed in gravity you know
what a poor idea or whatever you know it
doesn't even make sense but but but for
us it was like the perfect setup you
know because we were able about within
hours of supplying millions of faces
around the world that were the actual
face of global warming so the day starts
first in the Pacific so the first
picture that comes in is from underwater
on the dying coral reefs in the Marshall
Islands you can't have Coral
reefs in a hot acid ocean it doesn't
there may be it's an ecosystem that is
disappearing incredibly enchanting
corner of God's brain that just is being
carved out and in our lifetimes in front
of our eyes
I mean you would think in Indiana Stan
people had other things they had to
worry about but the fact that the Kabul
River is drying up is a pretty big one
you know and there's droughts all over
the place there's pictures from Kenya
Evon to sort of see what's going on and
you know sea level rise in all kinds of
places some places the damage is a
little less you know absolutely
life-threatening but hell if you like
too steep
it's bad that we don't really have
winter in quite the same way you know um
but everywhere everyone mean up in the
boreal forest where wildfire is now just
a ravine the huge wildfires this summer
in Alaska more than a million acres so
far and this is places that never have
burned because it wasn't you know it you
know there's Micronesia they're having
to start evacuating islands there move
people someplace else because the water
is rising too high that's at the Dead
Sea that red balloon is where the level
of the Dead Sea was 40 years ago
okay so then gives you some idea what's
going on you know that picture stuck in
my mind if just one of we have big
organization in India and there were
lots of anonymous villages like this one
you know where I liked it because you
could just faintly see that they you
know 350 was no sort of graffiti there
but the reason that it struck me was it
just came with a note and all the note
said was there is no water behind our
dam anymore and the same in all kinds of
places this is that zone in Pakistan I
was telling you about 20 million people
okay
forced out of their homes by flood it's
as if hurricane sandy had forced the
evacuation of everybody between
Baltimore and Boston you know
just just incredible to even think about
and the same from all over there's
Vermont MA where I live um Hurricane
Irene the year before steered just clear
of New York City and hammered us instead
and you can still see all the sand
that's you know it's the biggest thing
that ever happened in our state to
killed a bunch of people and that we're
gonna be paying for it for the next
twenty years trying to replace roads and
bridges god forbid we get another one in
that same period but doubtless we will
same all over the place all over the
place that was maybe the picture that
got me is probably the smallest
demonstration of the day and it was just
like something street that had turned
into a muddy river in Haiti but if just
these signs of your actions affect me
which indeed they do you know more
people died in Haiti from Hurricane
sandy than died in New York okay um your
actions affect me but it doesn't work
the other way around
there's actually very little that
anybody in Haiti can do to affect the
outcome of this story beyond appeal to
us the endowment of Columbia University
is greater than the GDP of Haiti I'm
almost sure they don't have the
headquarters of huge corporations to go
protest at they don't have you know a
few hours train ride away the the the
you know Executive Mansion of the one
superpower on earth where they can make
themselves heard they count on us to do
that and I want to just end by saying
you guys in program and many the rest of
you mean it's very important to talk and
think about things like global warming
and to research and understand them but
you know knowledge without action in
this case really is the ruin of the soul
we have to actually do something about
this and the things that we're called to
do I think get harder the further on we
move into this thing and I'll end with
just a couple of reflections about that
um
the civil disobedience that we organized
in Washington a couple of years ago I
was thinking about it over the weekend
because I was back in jail briefly in
California we did this demonstration
outside the refinery Chevron refinery in
Richmond California we did it for two
reasons one was to mark the one-year
anniversary of a section of that
refinery exploding in the middle of that
poor and working-class community and
sending 15,000 people to the hospital
chevron has casual disregard for its
neighbors and it has casual disregard
for its planet it gave the largest
campaign contribution post Citizens
United
I gave it two weeks before the last
election it gave it to make sure that
the house would stay in the hands of
climate deniers it was successful which
is why there'll be no legislation about
carbon prices or anything in the near
future so we were there at Chevron and
in handcuffs for a while and that's why
I was thinking back to this stuff we did
in DC and there were two things about
that protest that I just stick in my
mind and I want to stick in yours
the first was and I look at the very
wonderfully diverse demographics of this
audience the first was but when when I
wrote the letter that we sent out asking
people to come and it got signed by a
bunch of my friends by Naomi Klein and
Wendell Berry and other people but one
of the things we said was we don't think
college kids should have to be the only
cannon fodder here you know we know that
they'll come to get arrested and we know
that they're leading this movement
everywhere but really right now if
you're 22 and our economy you know it
takes a little bit of courage to get
arrest record one of the unmixed
blessings of growing older is past a
certain point what the hell are they
gonna do to you you know and it was good
to see that many of the people who came
to get arrested had hair lines like mine
you know we did not ask people how old
are you because that would be rude but
we did say I think cleverly who was
president
when you were born the two biggest
cohorts came from the FDR and the Truman
administration okay the last day there
was a guy arrested with the sign around
his neck he was 93 at a sign around his
neck that said World War 2 vet handle
with care
he was so old he'd been born in the
Warren Harding administration now I
studied American history in college and
I've forgotten there was a war on
Harding administration okay the point is
it was very good to see elders acting
like elders okay and we need people to
do that and frankly if there's anybody
in the room since this is a college who
happens to have tenure then this goes
triple for you okay
you're the most insulated safe people in
the entire world you know you have more
and if you don't use it for some power
than Zaman the second thing we said was
if you're gonna come get arrested
would you please would you wear a
necktie or a dress when you come and you
saw the pictures of people getting hold
on now that's you know I live in Vermont
we're not really very formally minded
you know um but we wanted to make a
visual point that undergirds everything
I've been saying here today which is
that there is nothing radical about what
we're talking about nothing at all okay
all we're asking for is a planet that
works the way the planet worked that we
were born on to the way that every
person whose history we know about the
last ten thousand years a planet that
worked the way that it worked for them
that's not a radical demand that's a
very conservative demand if you think
about it radicals work at oil companies
if you're willing to get up in the
morning and make a fortune by altering
the chemical composition of the
atmosphere then you are engaged in an
act far more radical than any human
being that ever came before you you make
any sort of 60s radical blush you know
with the scale of your ambition it's our
job to figure out how to
check that radicalism and how to check
it quickly enough to prevent it from
just overwhelming every good thing on
this planet and frankly there's no
guarantee that we are going to win this
fight those of you who've been studying
this and those of you who just sort of
know look around the world around you
know that really were quite far behind
that physics is ahead at this point okay
the Arctic melted last summer that's a
bad sign all right so I can't guarantee
that we're gonna win but I can guarantee
something thanks to people like May or I
see my other colleague Vanessa out there
in the audience and thanks to all the
other people all around the country in
the world who are working hard on this
everyday I can't guarantee you we're
gonna win but I can guarantee that
there's going to be a fight that it's
not gonna happen unopposed and that it's
going to be a fight equal to the kind of
historic scale of the problem that we
face that's a good thing to know it'll
be a pleasure for those of you who are
willing to get involved to just fight it
shoulder-to-shoulder with you going
forward thank you
all right
i rattled on i rambled on for a while
and I'm sorry about that I took more
time than I should but we did we have
time for some questions yes and there's
a I think a microphone in the middle for
questions you want to be in charge of
this phase of the operation so how
helpful is the media being um you know
look I'm I come from that world this has
not been a place where our journalistic
Enterprise has covered itself with glory
for a very long time the media treated
it as a sort of he-said she-said story I
think now at Columbia Journalism school
and elsewhere we sort of use it as a
prime example of what you might call
false equivalence we had 99% of science
as saying one thing but the 1% to her
saying the other got kind of equal time
and so people were left only in this
country really but with the kind of
distorted impression that's one of the
reasons that we've worked hard to kind
of build our own media in a sense and
and that's possible to do now in a way
that wasn't possible before when we were
started those civil disobedience that
around the Keystone stuff nobody would
cover it
it just was seemed so unlikely and so
you know well I remember one I remember
one reporter saying to me all this is
create this just seems like some David
and Goliath thing that you're doing
that's like dude do you know this story
you know that David wins right
in this thing so it was it was
infuriating in that sense but we were
able to use the web and to sort of get
the message out first to our own sort of
constituency and base and all the people
who would sort of respond and then it
sort of kept spreading of its own right
you know and until a certain point the
media had to write about it and by about
a year in it was pretty clear to me that
we had done what we set out to do the
day it really became clear to me was
when Mitt Romney released his first
television commercial of the general
election and his very first commercial
he said looking straight into the camera
in my first hour in office my first job
will be to approve the Keystone pipeline
and I was like wow I guess we've gotten
our message through you know um we put
something on the map he went on to say
which I thought was the sweetest draw
last thing I'd ever said if necessary I
will build it myself
he said which is just thinking about
Mitt Romney like you know sort of having
this is the end of the shovel that goes
in the ground sir you know here's how it
works you know
so this is good people in and that's one
of the reasons we organize the way we do
by localities you know do things close
to home and what it means is that like
the 350 chapter in wherever is usually
very engaged with just that kind of work
like 350 Vermont or I'm come from which
I have nothing to do with except watch
and applaud and they've sort of set
themselves up and they're working very
hard to reform regulatory stuff around
stuff in Vermont and at the same time
when there are big days of action they
come together to make a kind of national
and global statement to and it's that
mix of local national global that we're
gonna have to have in order to make this
work but you know what I mean none of us
can do all this sort of thing the may
what's this the we have about worldwide
the staff of 350.org is about 50 people
is that right a little bit less than 50
people we do what we can and we're very
glad that there are zillions of other
people doing what they can and the
beautiful thing about this movement as
its evolving is that it's essentially
it's not like sort of sixties movements
it's essentially leaderless and what it
looks like in practice as a movement is
kind of what we hope the energy system
will look like instead of a few big
power plants providing all the energy
tens of millions of solar panels on tens
of millions of rooftops linked together
to do what needs doing
that's have to do all these things you
have to address it globally - I mean
look one of the things that needs to
happen one of the policy things that
needs to happen is a price on carbon
when we get a price on carbon it will
convince an awful lot of people that
there's serious money to be made in
renewable energy at which point not
carbon trading know I think what Hansen
is called for is this fee and dividend
which is a really good policy and a
sensible one one that would put a price
on carbon and collect a serious tax from
the fossil fuel industry and then just
write a cheque to everybody in the
country every month for their share okay
the in essence the question is who owns
the sky Exxon or us you know and if
they're going to use it then they should
pay some rent and we can use the rent to
do things like put solar panels on our
roofs and whatever else that kind of
redistribution will be one useful part
there is no one answer to climate change
there is no silver bullet there may be
enough silver buckshot if we gather it
all up and the part you're talking about
is important part and a part that people
are deeply engaged in all throughout the
country that I know of certainly every
place I go
ya know they're very much on the radar
and people in Taos just in as I say in
California and people working hard to
try and forestall fracking one of the
one of the unfortunate maybe but useful
things about the fact that fracking
happened is one of the first times when
one of these energy extraction
technologies actually happened in a
relatively crowded and prosperous place
the northeastern United States so
Pennsylvania and Ohio and things and
people really noticed and saw and got
angry and stood up and and there's a lot
of that sentiment that's now spreading
west happily to California because the
fracking for oil in California it's a
North Dakota or larger size pool of oil
there and it becomes another one of
these things that we have to keep
underground one of the reasons that we
need a real price on carbon is that if
we get it it will put off limits
economically hard to get at stuff a
price on carbon won't be enough to keep
Saudi Arabian oil in the ground okay you
can get that out for $3 a barrel but if
you're gonna go frack it's gonna cost
you 70 $80 a barrel and any kind of
serious price on carbon would make that
a low priority compared to wind or Sun
or anything else but yet we also have to
stand up to it directly and people are
and those of us in New York those of you
in New York should continue very
strongly to press Governor Cuomo to make
sure that the moratorium on fracking in
this state stays intact
I will I will I will boast only to say
that Vermont is the one state in the
Union that is banned fracking altogether
so there is that joining joining Quebec
and France there's some something some
connection between you know good cheese
and sound environmental policy often
these campuses and well the hope is that
it will translate fairly quickly as it
did in the case of South Africa -
serious pressure on the industry to
change its ways I mean look the ultimate
goal here is yes but but but it becomes
because they're beginning to get serious
pressure on their bottom line
you know and on their political
legitimacy so there's going to be you
know not this Congress but maybe the
next one for instance they're going to
be serious proposals to do something
about safe putting a price on carbon and
we'll know how well we've done in
weakening the hand of the fossil fuel
industry when we see how many
legislators are willing to desert them
are more scared of us than of them and
getting that analysis out is as
important as the actual win on
divestment having people understand that
these guys plan to burn more carbon than
any scientist thinks is safe is a really
important meme to have solidly out there
all the time there's no there never is
in these kind of thing
a kind of a follows B follows C perfect
game plan for how it all works all that
we're trying to do is figure out how to
build a countervailing power to that
power and this is one of the ways and
it's worth remembering whenever we think
about divestment you know two-thirds of
them I have said earlier today
two-thirds of the most important people
in this country sit on college boards of
Trustees you know look at who's on the
Columbia or the NYU or whatever Board of
Trustees they should be having to think
at every single board meeting about who
it is that they're in bed with you know
and what it means and they should have
to feel bad about it over and over and
over again and eventually that will tell
one hopes it'll take a little while it
took six seven years of really good
organizing to get the South African
stuff to the point where they won but
when they did it was really significant
when Nelson Mandela got out of prison
the first foreign trip he took was to
the US and he did not go first to the
White House he went first to California
to thank students at the University of
California system they were one of a
hundred and fifty five campuses that
around the country that had divested
they divested forced the divestment of
three billion dollars worth of stock and
Mandela said look we fought for our own
liberation and that was key but we
couldn't have done it without you either
it took that kind of global pressure and
and so this is a fight very much worth
engaging and even though we don't know
exactly how it comes out I mean as a
historian in Colombia has a history here
because this was the first Ivy League
university of divest itself completely
I'm stuck with a South Africa and it
came after students I don't want to give
anybody
yes statement said occupied Hamilton
Hall for 18 days one of the many actions
may be taken on the campus here but
having said that historians are still
debating how much of a difference had
actually made in terms of the decisions
of the South African government as
opposed to the the work of South
Africans themselves and protesting in
the streets historians you know will
debate many things for many time I'll
take I'll take I'll take Nelson Mandela
and Desmond Tutu's work for it alright
so yeah I would say is that there's
actually history to learn from oh
because one of the things you find for
instance when you get inside the
corporate boardrooms the thing that
really worried them wasn't someone to
see effect on their stock prices and
there's almost no cases if it really did
depress it yeah they've been a
particular stock it was things like
selective purchasing like when
statements or or the ability to recruit
good new talent to come work at their
operations I mean one of the other
things that started happening was people
began making sure that when the you know
recruiters from whoever it was came to
campus they were greeted by the kind of
discussed they deserved to be greeted by
and this is already starting to happen
in many ways the first building takeover
of this era came last spring in
Providence Rhode Island when people at
the young people at the Rhode Island
School of Design took over their
administration building and they being
good artists it was extremely beautiful
and they um they hung out of the window
all these banners that said we may be
art students but we can still do the
math they said and I think that kind of
sentiments spreading um look there's no
there are many fronts in this fight none
of it none of it by itself accomplishes
what needs accomplishing none of it by
itself each part of it helps in a kind
of epic sense
all the time and there is a big price of
water but specifically the water from
the floods and what why do we always
live one pipeline if they were required
would like half a dozen of them to keep
some empty we could use them to like
diverge the wineries in the Mississippi
Powdersville
or three blowers some riverbeds ahead of
these two these storms is a way you know
that would be as you
box of solutions that seemed sensible
yeah my guess is that um common sense
probably at this point doesn't dictate
sending the Great Lakes off to the
southwest that it really dictates
keeping the temperature from rising
beyond the point where you can't live in
Phoenix on what's down there you know I
had two degrees centigrade is anybody
considering how to either contain that
no there's no way to contain it and it's
one of the reasons why the fight is so
desperate past a certain point we've
still got our hand to a certain degree
on the co2 thermostat if we make changes
in policy we'll put less carbon in the
atmosphere and hence the temperature go
up less but there's no if we raise the
temperature enough that we're causing
uncontrolled release of methane into the
atmosphere there's no thermostat we have
any control over there's no policy
option that refreezes the Arctic you
know so that's it's those kind of trip
wires are one of the reasons why beyond
the kind of steadies incredibly
dangerous world threatening kind of
linear thing we also should that I
described we also should be very worried
about sort of fat tail events that um
take us by surprise thank you because
this is very diffused there's no no no
practical way to take the whole tundra
and capture the methane coming out of it
it's an uncontrolled release from a vast
area
we speak into the mic I'm from Mistral
so for me the images are there that's
right there they're always a lot of you
know what what academics is things are
over determined you know there are many
causes but the hydrologists are pretty
clear for example that virgin flows
along the Jordan should already a river
that's over stretched you know that's
called upon to do more than it can are
pretty clear that virgin flows along in
Jordan are expected to drop something
like 80 percent in the course of this
century because of warmer temperature um
there are places in Israel maybe one of
them that have enough money to maybe
desalinate enough water to keep going
but that doesn't describe most of the
world and that desalination will require
vast quantities of energy thereby
increasing this cycle so I think it pays
to pay attention to climate change on
top of all the other dumb things that
we've done around the world to our
environment we'd be in get me wrong we'd
be in but it'd be plenty for us to work
on even if the climate wasn't changing
okay but the fact that the climate is
changing
we'll make moot all the other work we're
doing on everything else unless we take
care of that sort of first and foremost
I think people there were pretty clear
that this was you know that's what
people there on the shores of the Dead
Sea were saying this is related in large
part to climate change and we know
what's going to happen to this place in
the future from climate change and they
seem very comfortable with doing it I
think it was actually a really beautiful
day around the Dead Sea to watch people
in Israel and Palestine and Jordan able
to cooperate and think about that stuff
together which I think was a really nice
thing and rare enough in that region but
I want those people that always looks
for the practicalities and I think that
there's a great place for as you talked
about losing shame yield angry choices
to power structure healthy change but I
also see these extremely important for
people to be inspired and feel how and
to me the greatest obstacle to change is
to see you know it really doesn't matter
do I think that I knew how this
residents so forceful I feel that if I
feel inspired to find out much more
about what the Europeans have done
because this always well yes this is
terrible but how they get prepared there
you just let it stop all the off there I
have a question for just the question is
if we were in the u.s. what to do as
much as has been done in Germany and
Norway for example
it'd be really significant I mean I mean
if we were putting up if we had the
scene mr. Krauss you know sort of per
capita across the US as they do across
Germany you'd be producing a lot of
power
mostly because they'd be in places with
a lot more sunlight you know then then
Germany we could be doing all kinds of
things I mean and there are plenty of
places that are so let me give you an
example
okay let's dump just something about
Germany let's think about a much poorer
part of the world think about China I
did a piece for National Geographic on
China and energy a couple years ago and
one of the people that I talked to was a
guy named Guang Ming an engineer who
runs heme in solar the biggest solar
thermal solar hot water company in the
world now some of you have been to China
doubtless in recent years and you've
noticed that there are an enormous
number of building solar hot water
panels on the roof okay about 25 percent
of Chinese 250 and 300 million people
basically the population in the US get
their domestic hot water from solar
panels on the roof that compares in this
country with less than 1% of people okay
and even most of that 1% is used for
heating swimming pools um now when I
spent the day with this guy long Ming
the most interesting part of it was not
the endless description of the quite
simple but elegant technology of doing
solar hot water the most interesting
thing was when he took me to see his
private museum and he said here's my
favorite you know a lot of pictures of
him shaking hands with world leaders but
then but the pride of place is this
rusting solar hot water panel as you
know what that is no what's that that's
my favorite thing that's one of the
solar hot water panels that Jimmy Carter
put on the White House in 1979 and
Ronald Reagan took down in 1985 okay and
the point being in the end this is about
structures and systems it's about
politics it's about building the
political will to do those things and
it's a great should be a great source of
shame for us and and economically it is
a great source of shame for us that a
technology where we had the clear lead
we then ceded to somebody else you know
people who know how to do solar power
are going to be better off this century
than people like us who have mastered
the 17th century technology of coal you
know it's a important thing yes
absolutely you need a different speaker
to come to the inspiration part I'm much
better good an inspiration so you have
our back a lot of people still in ask
questions I don't know if we're gonna
get to all them but I would ask everyone
please just ask one question so this
year your your friend this can also ask
a question
before accidents the journal had picture
a favorite animal accidents like this
people so take a picture I'd be
interested in hearing how you carry
weight sure I mean yes I mean yes the
industry arm is do this or will kill you
with our train cars um I mean the real
answer is the reason that we oppose the
pipeline above all else is because by
opposing the pipeline we can stop the
expansion of tar sands development in
Canada they can take a little bit out by
rail but not that much taking it out by
rail adds twenty twenty-five dollars a
barrel to the cost of transporting it
that's why they want to build the
pipeline and so it becomes uh neck
anomic to do it that's why they work
spend hundreds of millions of dollars
running ads to let them build a pipeline
so we will if we're successful in
beating the keystone pipeline the
financing for expanding the tar sands
will dry out is already starting to dry
up because we've added two years to the
timetable already you know that's what
the fights about in the end and you know
oil I mean that tar sands oil particular
is dirty where it comes from
I mean they've wrecked the lives and
landscape of a beautiful part of the
world people have inhabited for a long
time it's dirty along the way when it
spills or blows up or whatever and of
course the biggest problem is it's
filthy when it reaches its intended
destination the gas tank of somebody's
car and gets turned into co2 then it
does things like melt the Arctic I mean
we think the one study that anybody has
done predicted that climate change would
be killing a hundred million people by
2030 almost all of them in the developed
world those are the kind of numbers that
we're talking about
and he's a great guy he W to 350 for my
birthday yeah you know it's really into
in my motherly Gardens you know
composter but he also you know whatever
things you desire toward gives you
vitamin C stops and I'm stopping Chevron
and easy way he's a very open guy and
you love to talk about things and myself
you should divest a nice time can be
said in a very calm and nice way so
here's let's go beyond all this sort of
moral is just talk is I mean as an
investor okay let's so the smartest well
there's an easy way to tell who the best
investors are okay because they're the
richest people okay so the richest guy I
actually know is this guy named Tom
Steyer California Bay Area started the
biggest one of the biggest hedge funds
in the country Farallon Capital
Management he's on the Forbes 400 list
of whatever it is you know biggest
plutocrats on earth you know last year
he stepped down as head of his hedge
fund because he said hey I don't morally
want to be invested in fossil fuel
anymore and B I think it's a terrible
investment anyway going forward I think
it's a huge bubble and that people who
are invested in it are going to get
caught in that bubble just like they got
caught in the housing bubble seven or
eight years ago and so he's written the
letter that we've been passing out to
college boards of trustees saying look
you guys have inside information you're
insiders in this sense everybody else is
relying on the Wall Street Journal you
know which is feeding them nonsense
about climate change
yeah your university you have a physics
department it is filled with people who
can tell you about the size of this
carbon bubble and what's going to happen
so you should trade on your inside
information and get the hell out of this
car
bubble before it blows up in your face
and so so everything else aside or on
top of all the other good things that
Patrick is doing it just makes good
sense for his portfolio to get the hell
out from under these guys
I think receding today and thank you for
the shout out to grow I'm Daniella and
November Friday Columbia that UPS here
and I just wanna say I just wanna say
that grow is a series of nationwide Mia
organized by fossil fuel divestment
students it stands for gathering rise
organize and win most importantly and
this Saturday we have a media plan in
Brooklyn and we'd love for you to come
the URL is grow divestment work and if
you want any info about what bargain
pluggy that up today feel free to come
talk to me afterwards or Ryan or our URL
Department Colombia that must not work
thank you very much for being with us
first I'd like to say that I think
top-siders would probably publish
something on course or Wall Street
Journal it would be something beneficial
for a lot of people because essentially
second of all I have a quick question
with regards to the racket I was trying
to find specific article over on my cell
phone
some of our myths have been made that if
we do allow for more use and more
extraction of natural gas with oil it
would become more competitive with with
: City right which we've actually
probably beneficial to this is the
argument we used to people used to say
it's a gas is a bridge to the future as
we're waiting you notice we're instead
of developing solar power right away or
as we're learning how to do it this is a
less because when you burn natural gas
it produces about half as much carbon
per BTU as burning coal okay so there's
two problems here one is that's true
about when you burn it when you don't
burn it when it released released
straight into the atmosphere ch4 methane
is about 25 times more potent molecule
for molecule than co2 in trapping heat
so you have to devise a system that
leaks less than two percent or so of
methane and fracking since it's you know
involves breaking things apart whatever
is a kind of system to leak a lot of
stuff into the atmosphere we don't have
good numbers but in fact there was a new
study today from Utah as they flew drone
aircraft with sensing equipment over
fracking fields in Utah they were
finding 8 to 15 percent leakage rates if
that's anything like that's true it's
way worse than coal the second problem
is even if it was only half as bad as
coal
we've wasted the time which in which we
could have had that bridge one of the
things I have to restrain myself from
doing and I won't quite be able to hear
today is since I wrote the first book
about this 25 years ago there are times
when I want to say oh if only you'd
listened to me
okay because 25 years ago we actually
had a series of trajectories that were
where we could have done other things
and and you know we wouldn't have solved
climate change by now but we'd be well
on the way if we were gonna build a
bridge 1989 was a good time to do it
okay now the Arctic's melted now the
bridge now it doesn't look like a bridge
now it just looks like a gangplank you
know and we hacked instead of looking
for this mythical bridge all the time we
actually have to take the leap you know
and do the renewables now it's just
physics the numbers just don't work
anymore in those ways so good question
well of course going to the oil industry
one day and there was something to love
them talking to them about climate
change issues because I know that
they're good people and I want to
talking about this in a way that doesn't
make it seem like a personal attack yeah
I think I mean there's no way to get
around the fact that the oil industry is
now a ruinous industry and that one you
should try to persuade people not to go
into it for their life's work in part
because with any luck it's not going to
be there for their whole life if you you
know if we're even at all rational as a
planet twenty years from now we'll be
trying desperately not to find new oil
every new bit of oil that any geologist
finds is a problem now not a help okay
but that is I mean you can do that
without saying you're a criminal for
doing this you know it's just that the
it's just that physics calls the tune
here you know we're up against a problem
of physics of numbers and when people
realize that as scientists in general
have realized as the scientific and even
now geologists I got into some the gold
medal there's the presidents
or something of the American Society of
geologists last year and it was quite an
interesting thing because you know this
this is in a discipline that for years
the biggest employer has been the
petroleum industry and things but people
are beginning to understand that that's
got to change
so without being I mean I have no animus
toward most people in the oil industry I
can't stand the people who run it who
know very good and well what they're
doing and continue to try and corrupt
the political process so that they can
keep doing what they're doing that's
wrong and those people are bad people um
but but yeah I think you can just make
the case with anybody who has a
scientific background that is just you
know we happen to be alive at the moment
when this no longer makes mathematical
sense we just can't do it it's been very
good he's been speaking for three hours
now because we had a seminar before this
and there's a problem of numbers and
questions thank you all right thank you
all
you